a few years ago i found myself
in kigali rwanda presenting a plan to
bring
off-grid solar electricity to 10 million
low-income
east africans as i waited to speak to
the president and his ministers
i thought about how i'd arrived in that
same place
30 years before a 25 year old who left
her career in banking
to co-found the nation's first
microfinance bank with a small group of
rwandan women
and that happened just a few months
after women had gained the right
to open a bank account without their
husband's signature
just before i got on stage a young woman
approached me
miss novogratz she said i think you knew
my auntie
really what was her name
she said feligula
i could feel tears well one of the first
women parliamentarians in the country
feligilla was a co-founder
but soon after we'd established the bank
felicia was killed in a mysterious
hit-and-run
accident some associated her death
to a policy she'd sponsored to abolish
bride price
or the practice of paying a man for the
hand of his daughter in marriage
i was devastated by her death
and then a few years after that after
i'd left the country
wanda exploded in genocide
and i have to admit there were times
when i thought about
all the work so many had done
and i wondered what it had amounted to
i turned back to the woman i'm sorry
would you tell me
who you are again she said yes my name
is monique
and i'm the deputy governor of wanda's
national bank
if you had told me when we were just
getting started
that within a single generation a young
woman
will go on to help lead her nation's
financial sector
not sure i would have believed you and i
understood
that i was back in that same place
to continue work felicia had started but
could not complete in her lifetime
and that it was to me to recommit to
dreams so big
i might not complete them in mine that
night i decided
to write a letter to the next generation
because so many have passed on their
wisdom
and knowledge to me because i feel a
growing sense of
urgency that i might not finish the work
i came to do
and because i want to pass that forward
to everyone who wants to create change
in this world in ways that only they can
do
that generation is in the streets
they are crying urgently for wholesale
change
against racial injustice religious and
ethnic persecution
catastrophic climate change and the
cruel inequality that has left us more
divided
and divisive than ever in my lifetime
but what would i say to them i'm a
builder so i started by focusing
on technical fixes
but our problems are too interdependent
to entangled we need more
than a system shift we need a mind shift
plato wrote that a country cultivates
what it honors
for too long we have defined success
based on money
power and fame now we have to start the
hard
long work of moral revolution
by that i mean putting our shared
humanity and the sustainability of the
earth
at the center of our systems and
prioritizing the collective we
not the individual i what if each of us
gave more to the world than we took from
it
everything would change now
cynics might say that sounds too
idealistic
but cynics don't create the future and
though i've learned the folly of
unbridled optimism
i stand with those who hold to
hard-edged hope
i know that change is possible the
entrepreneurs and change agents with
whom my team and i have worked
have impacted more than 300 million
low-income people
and sometimes reshaped entire sectors to
include the poor
but you can't really talk about moral
revolution without grounding it
in practicality and meaning and that
requires an
entirely new set of operating principles
let me share just three the first is
moral imagination
too often we use the lens only of our
own imagination
even when designing solutions for people
whose lives are completely different
from our own
moral imagination starts by seeing
others as equal to ourselves neither
above nor below
us neither idealizing nor victimizing
it requires immersing in the lives of
others understanding the structures
that get in their way and being honest
about where they might be holding
themselves back
that requires deep listening from a
place of inquiry
not certainty several years ago i sat
with a group of
women weavers outside in a rural village
in pakistan
the day was hot over 120 degrees in the
shade
i wanted to tell the women about a
company my organization had invested in
that was bringing solar light to
millions of people
across india and east africa and i had
seen the transformative power of that
light
to allow people to do things so many of
us just
take for granted we have this light i
said
costs about seven dollars people say
it's amazing
if we could convince the company to
bring those products to pakistan
would you all be interested the women
stared
and then a big woman whose hands knew
hard work looked at me
wiped the sweat off her face and said
we don't want a light we're hot bring us
a fan fan i said
we don't have a fan we have a light but
if you have this light
your kids can study at night you can
work more she's cut me off
we work enough we're hot bring us a fan
that straight talking conversation
deepened
my moral imagination and i remember
lying
sweltering in my bed in my tiny guest
house that night
so grateful for the clickety clack of
the fan
overhead and i thought of course
electricity a fan dignity
and when i now visit our companies
who've reached over 100 million people
with light and electricity
and it's a really hot place if there's a
rooftop system
there's also a fan but moral imagination
is also
needed to rebuild and heal our countries
my nation is roiling as it finally
confronts what it's not wanted to see
it would be impossible to deny the
legacy of american slavery
if all of us truly immersed in the lives
of black people
every nation begins the process of
healing
when its people begin to see each other
and to understand that it is in that
work
that are planted the seeds of our
individual and collective
transformation now that
requires acknowledging the light and
shadow of the good and evil that exist
in every human being
in our world we have to learn to partner
with those even whom we consider are
adversaries
this leads to the second principle
holding
opposing values in tension too many of
our leaders today
stand on one corner of the other
shouting
moral leaders reject the wall of either
or
they're willing to acknowledge a truth
or even a partial truth
in what the other side believes and they
gain trust
by making principled decisions in
service of
other people not themselves
to succeed in my work has required
holding the tension between the power of
markets to enable innovation
and prosperity and their peril
to allow for exclusion and sometimes
exploitation
those who see the sole purpose of
business as profit
are not comfortable with that tension
nor are those who have no trust in
business at all
but standing on either side negates
the creative generative potential of
learning to use markets
without being seduced by them take
chocolate
it's a hundred billion dollar industry
dependent on the labor of about five
million smallholder farming families
who receive only a tiny fraction of that
hundred billion
in fact ninety percent of them make
under two dollars a day but there's a
generation of new entrepreneurs
that is trying to change that they start
by understanding
the production costs of the farmers they
agree
to a price that allows the farmers to
actually
earn income in a way that will sustain
their lives
sometimes including revenue share and
ownership models
building a community of trust now
are these companies as profitable as
those that focus solely on shareholder
value
possibly not in the short term but these
entrepreneurs
are focused on solving problems
they're tired of easy slogans like doing
well by doing good
they know they have to be financially
sustainable and they
are insisting on including the poor and
the vulnerable in their definition of
success
and that brings me to the third
principle accompaniment
it's actually a jesuit term that means
to walk alongside
i'll hold a mirror to you help you see
your potential maybe more than you say
it yourself
i'll take on your problem but i can't
solve it for you
that you have to learn to do for example
in harlem
there's an organization called city
health works that
hires local residents with no previous
health care experience
trains them to work with other residents
so that they can better control chronic
diseases like gout
hypertension diabetes i had the great
pleasure of meeting destiny belton one
of the health workers
who explained her job to me she said
that she checks in on clients
checks their vital signs takes them
grocery shopping goes on long walks
has conversations she told me
i let them know somebody has their back
and the results have been astounding
patients are healthier hospitals less
burden
as for destiny she tells me her family
and she
are healthier and she adds
i love that i get to contribute to my
community
all of us yearn to be seen
to count the work of change of moral
revolution
is hard but we don't change in the easy
times
we change in the difficult times in fact
i've come to see
discomfort as a proxy for progress
but there's one more thing there's
something i wish i'd known
when i was just starting out so many
years ago
no matter how hard it gets there's
always beauty to be found
i remember now what seems a long time
ago spending an entire day
talking to woman after woman in the
mathari valley slum
in nairobi kenya i listened to their
stories of struggle
and survival as they talked about losing
children
of fighting violence and hunger
sometimes feeling like they wouldn't
even survive
and right before i left a huge rain
storm
poured down and i was sitting in my
little car
as the wheel stuck in the mud thinking
i'm never getting out of here
when suddenly there was a tap on my
window and a woman who was beckoning me
to follow her
and i did i jumped out through the
rainstorm we went down this
little muddy path through a rickety
metal door
inside a shack where a group of women
were dancing with abandon
i jumped in and found myself lost in the
rhythm and then
and the color and the smiles and
suddenly i realized
this is what we do as human beings
when we're broken when we feel that we
are failing or are
in despair we dance
we sing we pray
beauty resides too in showing up
and paying attention and being kind when
we feel like being
anything but kind look at the
explosion of art and music and poetry
in this moment our collective crisis
it is in the darkest times that we have
the chance
to find our deepest beauty so
let this be our moment
to move forward with the fierce urgency
of a new generation
fortified with our most profound
and collective wisdom
and ask yourself what can you do
with the rest of today and the rest of
your life
to give back more to the world than you
take
thank you